alors que son nom d'un album c'est de la
merde et coutumes a demandé je lui
répondis mais là faut retrancher parce
que ça commence à bien faire
c'est la dernière fois que tu fais ce
métier tu m'entends tu m'emmerdes et
quand je parle avec ma femme occupe la
scène travaillée dans la finesse et en
beauce comme un crs qui venise était
devenu trop violent la seule chose que
je propose est une chanteuse légèreté
ray telle était pas obligé par tous
comme un service pour nous former sort
du toi t'as jamais fait de théâtre à
civelli terrain fout la paix à rihanna
lui font la paire allez bonne et annonce
un truc avant la fin et 36 j'aurai la
main dans ce strict est ce que tu vas
plus mon moteur qu'est-ce que tu es en
train de faire
qu'est-ce que tu trafiques que tout
construit aujourd'hui voulait dire qu'on
accès aux jardins secrets des stars à ok
j'adore ce job vous regardez le mec de
revenge avec un tapin l'a bien choisie
était bien [ __ ] a construit par la
famille aurait pu le dire plus tôt y'a
pas de mal être cocus l'ain
m
à quel moment vous vous dites que c'est
une bonne idée d'amener votre client
chez le type qui veut la tuer l'espion
travail de flics ce trac d'abrutis
[ __ ] mais vous arrêtez jamais moi ça
[ __ ] comique
ça sur youtube c'est un million de vues
direct
si tu montes pas dans la voiture on va
faire deux millions de vu tout le
bourinos cosec conan le barbare
tu crois qu'il ya un délire possibles
dont janis et moi j'ai parasites sens là
pour moi [ __ ] d'accord ok cash
pistache disant que alors moi j'adore
contourne le salon guiche aux tournées
bullish
j'ai une image oui bah vous me l'avez
peut-être vu j'ai l'image